[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute
Mitri Ihnen allen einen schönen guten
Abend mit mir im Studio für den Sport
ist Katja streso auch von mir einen
schönen guten Abend dann schauen wir auf
unsere heutigen Themen
Überlebensfaktor Treibstoff das un
Hilfswerk für Gasa warnt davor dass die
humanitäre Versorgung
zusammenbricht zu wenig Personal und
kosten die Gewerkschaft Nahrung Genuss
gaststätdten berät über die Krise in der
Gastronomie von Sportwetten bis
Spielautomaten Millionen Menschen in
Deutschland sind süchtig nach
Glücksspiel ein Milliardengeschäft für
den
Staat wir sind in Woche 6 seit Beginn
des Krieges zwischen Israel und der
palästinensischen Terrororganisation
Hamas auch wenn immer wieder Korridore
für Flüchtlinge errichtet werden die
humanitäre Situation im Gazastreifen ist
katastrophal vor allem in den umkämpften
Gebieten im Norden Stefan Leif hat
berichtet schon vom Grenzzaun aus kann
man das Ausmaß der Zerstörung im
Gazastreifen erkennen 4300 Angriffe hat
das israelische Militär nach eigenen
Angaben seit Beginn der Bodenoffensive
ausgeführt bei 3000 Zielen habe es sich
um terroristische Infrastruktur
gehandelt weil die Hamas laut Israel
ihre Strukturen mitten in der zivil
Infrastruktur unterhält nimmt dort nun
die humanitäre Katastrophe ihren Lauf
Bilder aus einem Krankenhaus der Stadt
kanjunis nach einem Bombenangriff in der
Umgebung unter den Opfern auch Kinder
wir wissen nicht was passiert ist der
Angriff traf uns plötzlich als wir
einfach da saßen wir saßen auf der
Straße und dann kam der
Angriff Israels Militär veröffentlicht
heute Bilder die zeigen sollen wie sich
Terroristen mit Panzerfäusten im alkut
Krankenhaus verschanzen es kam zu
Kämpfen bei denen
Terroristen nach Armeeangaben getötet
wurden in einem Haus im Norden des
Gazastreifens fanden die Soldaten ein
Waffenlager der Terrororganisation
islamischer Jihad ein Video soll den
Fund
belegen wir haben viele Waffen gefunden
kampfwesten und Uniform und daneben
standen Fotos von iranischen Führern in
den Krankenhäusern des Gazastreifens
spitzt sich die humanitäre Situation
weiter zu immer mehr Patienten werden
aus den Krankenhäusern des in den Süden
gebracht wir haben unser Kind erst ins
Krankenhaus in javalia gebracht dann
musste es wegen der schweren
Kopfverletzung ins alschifer Krankenhaus
dort konnten wir auch nicht bleiben nun
sind wir hier im
Süden es fehlt an Strom an Benzin für
Generatoren an medizinischen Gütern die
Krankenhäuser werden immer mehr zum
Drama im Drama dieses
Kriegs seit Beginn des gaserrieges sind
dort auch mehr als Mitarbeiter der
Vereinten Nationen ums Leben gekommen am
Sitz der UN Hilfsorganisationen in Genf
gab es deshalb heute eine Schweigeminute
Gedenken an 101 Kolleginnen und Kollegen
die in den vergangenen Wochen in Gaza
getötet wurden Trauer auch am Hauptsitz
in New York noch nie hatte die UNO in so
kurzer Zeit so viele Todesopfer in den
eigenen Reihen zu
beklagen die Lage in narost sei ein
absolutes Dilemma sagte Annalena berbock
in Brüssel wo heute die EU Außenminister
beraten ein Dilemma auch dass Europa
gerade in diesem weltpolitisch
aufgeladenen Konflikt nicht mit einer
Stimme spricht Frankreich und
Deutschland verfolgen einen
unterschiedlichen Kurs mehr über das
Außenministertreffen jetzt von Ulf
Roller noch einmal genau nachlesen denn
es kommt auf jedes Wort an das ganze
Wochenende hat der EU Außenbeauftragte
Borell an der Erklärung der
Außenminister zum Konflikt im Nahen
Osten gearbeitet ein Kompromiss damit
die EU geeint
wirkt wir fordern sofortige Feuerpausen
um humanitäre Korridore zu schaffen um
die dramatische Situation der
Zivilbevölkerung in Gaza zu lindern und
wir fordern von Israel größtmögliche
Zurückhaltung Feuerpausen sind keine
Waffenruhe gegen die ist die deutsche
Außenministerin genauso wie der
Bundeskanzler allerdings bringt unter
and der französische Präsident macron
immer wieder eine Waffenruhe ins Spiel
auch bbock hat einen Zettel dabei denn
sie muss den Streit in der EU klein
ren wenn wir gemeinsam eine Position
formulieren so schwer das manchmal auch
ist so hitzig die Diskussionen dann
haben wir unsere Union als Werte Union
als klares Fundament die EU hat sich
jahrelang nicht auf eine gemeinsame
naosstrategie einigen können das reche
sich jetzt sagt Luxemburgs außenminister
Jean Asselborn der seit mehr als 20
Jahren dabei ist es ist sein letzter
Auftritt und ermahnt jetzt sagt jeder
wir brauchen eine Z statenlesung aber
wir haben 10 Jahre wenigstens 10 Jahre
nicht mehr daran gearbeitet und nicht
daran geglaubt die EU ringt wieder
einmal mit der Frage um die Zukunft im
Nahen Osten die Zeit
drängt ja ZF heute hält sie wie gewohnt
jederzeit auf dem Laufenden und jetzt
auch unter Aktuelles bei what App zu
finden scannen Sie dafür einfach den
angezeigten QR-Code oder abonnieren Sie
uns direkt bei Whatsapp selbst die
Nachrichtenlage kompakt zusammengefasst
mit den Updates am Morgen und am
Abend jetzt zu einem politischen
Paukenschlag in Großbritannien
Regierungschef rishy sunek holt mit
David Cameron völlig überraschend einen
seiner Vorgänger als neuen Außenminister
ins Regierungsteam ausgerechnet Cameron
der den brexit nicht wollte doch darüber
abstimmen ließ und danach als Premier
zurücktrat im politischen London wird
die Personalie sehr aufgeregt und
kontrovers diskutiert mehr jetzt von
Hilke Petersen David Cameron zurück im
Regierungsgeschäft manche im politischen
London beschreiben das als Schock dabei
hatte Premierminister sunak gerade
neulich von der parteitagsbühne change
ausgerufen die große Veränderung
konservativer
[Applaus]
Politik s der vergangenen 30 Jahre
verändern zu wollen und bringt nun den
zurück der genau das so verkörpert wie
kein anderer lebender Politiker und
setzt ihnen eins der wichtigsten Ämter
das er finden
konnte doch immerhin tritt mit Cameron
einer an der international einen Namen
und Erfahrung hat zu China hat er
umstritten gute dräte und damit eher ein
Problem Cameron lässt heute wissen als
Außenminister wolle er den Verbündeten
zur Seite stehen meint die Ukraine und
Israel
2016 am Tag nach dem brexit Referendum
war Cameron zurückgetreten er gilt als
Urheber des eu-austritts mit all den
quälenden
Debatten die Kabinettsumbildung hatte
suella bravan provoziert mit
rechtspopulistischen Slogans hassmärsche
hatte die Innenministerin die
proalästinensischen Proteste der
vergangenen Wochen genannt und der
Polizei vorgeworfen nicht durchzugreifen
das Innenministerium geht jetzt an James
cleverly bisher Außenminister der nun
für die schwierige Asylpolitik steuern
muss der Druck groß denn vor den Wahlen
im kommenden Jahr liegt Zak deutlich
zurück in den Umfragen David Cameron zu
reaktivieren das soll sicher auch ein
Hingucker sein für die internationalen
Partner innerhalb Großbritanniens könnte
sunak das Signal senden wollen dass der
brexit Krieg vorbei ist und er
pragmatisch handelt nicht ideologisch
warum sunak niemanden für den wichtigen
Posten in seinem Kabinett fand das
Deuten viele als ein Zeichen von
Schwäche
sehen sie hin und hören Sie zu nur ein
wachsames und aufgeklärtes Umfeld könne
Kinder vor sexueller Gewalt schützen so
Bundesfamilienministerin Paus im Kampf
gegen Kindesmissbrauch hat sie heute
eine neue Kampagne gestartet die sich an
Erwachsene richtet sie seien in der
Verantwortung und mit dieser Botschaft
beginnt der Bericht von Heike slanski es
gibt einen Menschen der spürt wenn etwas
nicht stimmt der hinhört auch wenn ich
nichts sag
und der hinsieht wenn ich plötzlich ganz
anders bin ein Fernsehspot der
Bundesregierung Teil einer mehrjährigen
Kampagne gegen sexuellen Missbrauch
schiebt deine Verantwortung nicht weg
die Zahlen erschütternd mehr als 17000
Mädchen und Jungen unter 14 Jahren sind
im vergangenen Jahr Opfer sexueller
Gewalt geworden das heißt in fast jedem
siebten Fall ist ist ein Kind unter 6
Jahren das hilfetelefon bei sexuellen
Missbrauch erreichbar sowohl für
Betroffene als auch Helfer die einen
Verdacht geschöpft haben viele Menschen
die uns anrufen die sind total nervös
und ganz aufgeregt und es erfordert ganz
schön viel Mut das zu tun laut Studien
kennen zwei Drittel der Betroffenen
ihren Peiniger Eltern Verwandte oder
Bekannte deshalb gelte sensibilisieren
und aufklären jeder einzelne sei gefragt
genauer zuhören ernst nehmen ein Mädchen
will nicht mehr am Nachmittag die
Großeltern besuchen der Bart vom Opa
kratzt so Hinhören Nachfragen Abgrenzung
ernst nehmen auch wenn es um den
Großvater den Stiefvater oder auch den
eigenen Partner geht unbequeme Gedanken
nicht wegschieben ein Appell um Kinder
und Jugendliche besser zu schützen
egal ob Restaurant oder Kneipe ausgehen
genießen Menschen treffen das ist
beliebt und das gehört zum sozialen Kit
unserer Gesellschaft aber die
Gastronomen klagen einerseits müssen sie
mit steigenden Kosten klarkommen für
Lebensmittel Energie mieten und es fehlt
ja auch Personal fast die Hälfte aller
Azubis gibt auf und auf der anderen
Seite wollen oder können viele Kunden
nicht mehr so viel Geld fürs Essen gehen
ausgeben immer mehr Betriebe müssen
schließen David Römhild über eine
Branche die Alarm schlägt reichen die
Brötchen noch oder brauchen wir noch
mehr kleinere Brötchen backen das will
dilif Pauls lieber nicht beim
Mittagstisch liege seine Gewinnspanne
bereits bei 0 € sagt der Hotelier der
Gastronom muss knapp kalkulieren steigen
mit der Mehrwertsteuer bald nun die
Preise bleiben die Gäste ganz weg so
seine Sorge es werden sicherlich viele
Betriebe schließen müssen oder einfach
aufgeben weil es einfach da nicht mehr
wirtschaftlich ist und
Unternehmen muss auch wirtschaftlich
sein es kann sich keiner leisten das aus
nächsten libe zu machen der
Mehrwertsteuersatz war während der
coronapandemie gesenkt worden auf
Speisen in Restaurants werden seit 2020
nur 7% erhoben ab 2024 könnten nun 19%
wieder fällig werden unglücklich nennt
die Gewerkschaft Nahrung Genuss
Gaststätten diesen Zeitpunkt genau wie
Gastronom Pauls beschäftigt sie der
Fachkräftemangel den habe die Pandemie
nur verschärft die eigentlicheurs sein
unattraktive Arbeitsbedingungen und
mangelnde Wertschätzung für den Beruf
das ist zum einen die schlechte
Bezahlung das sind die langen
Arbeitszeiten das sind die unbezahlten
Überstunden und das führt dazu dass mit
den Füßen abgestimmt wird die Menschen
gehen einfach aus der Branche raus und
suchen sich andere Jobs wo sie bessere
Arbeitsbedingungen haben bessere
Bedingungen und bei der niedrigen
Mehrwertsteuer bleiben das fordert
Hotelier Pauls damit sich nicht noch
mehr Stammgäste verabschieden
Glücksspiel ist eine gefährliche und oft
auch eine verborgene sucht an Automaten
online und immer stärker auch bei
Sportwetten das zeigen Forscher im
aktuellen glücksspielatlas demnach sind
in Deutschland
4,6 Millionen Erwachsene spielsüchtig
oder zeigen Symptome dafür besonders
gefährdet sind Männer junge Menschen
zwischen 21 und 35 und auch Mens mit
Migrationshintergrund das ganze ein
Riesengeschäft auch für den ST 2021 nahm
er 5,2 Milliarden Euro Steuern ein mehr
als für Alkohol Brit
spiermann der Spielsüchtige möchte nicht
erkannt werden die Stimme ist
nachgesprochen seine Suchtgeschichte
beginnt 2003 am roulettisch schnell
verliert er die Kontrolle und sehr viel
Geld wenn sie richtig drinne sind sind
sie 24 Stunden dabei in G wie können sie
spielen wie können sie Geld bekommen und
sie müssen noch ihren Alltag auch
irgendwie verbringen zur Arbeit gehen
keiner darf es anmerken Spielhallen
wachsen manche Orts wie Pilze aus dem
Boden Glücksspiel ist in Deutschland mit
einer Lizenz legal besonders Sportwetten
nehmen zu auch die Werbung in Stadien
oder online der Staat verdient mit
Steuereinnahmen in Milliardenhöhe im
ersten glücksspielatlass der Regierung
ist vom Big Business die Rede dem
grenzenzogen werden müssten besonders
dem illegalen Glücksspiel die Branche
selber redet von jedem dritten oder
vierten Gerät was aufgestellt wird dass
es zum illegalen Bereich gehört und
damit reden wir über einen riesen
Milliardenmarkt der sich zur Zeit
jeglicher Kontrolle entzieht die
Forderungen das straf und Ordnungsrecht
müsste verschärft die Werbung besonders
für Sportwetten eingedämmt werden
spielsucht ist ein Teufelskreis Geld
verlieren neues Geld auftreiben hohe
Schulden Angehörige sind da häufig auch
erstmal hilflos
und rufen dann hier auch an teilweise
und fragen was was soll ich denn jetzt
eigentlich machen ich geb ihm oder ihr
dann jetzt einfach noch mal das Geld in
der Hoffnung jetzt wird's
anders das funktioniert aber in den
allerseltensten Fällen es gibt
hilfetelefone und Therapien die
Suizidgefahr bei Spielsüchtigen ist
groß die deutschen Aktivist von Fridays
for future haben sich wieder von
klimaikone Greta tünberg distanziert für
Antisemitismus sei in der Bewegung kein
Platz die Schwedin war gestern bei einer
großen klimakundgebung in Amsterdam
zusammen mit palästinensischen
Aktivisten aufgetreten ein Klimaschützer
der sie deswegen zur rete stellen wollte
wurde von der Bühne entfernt tünberg
skandierte auf besetztem Land gäbe es
keine Klimagerechtigkeit kritiker werfen
ihr seit Wochen vor dass sie die Opfer
des hamasterrors
ignoriere jetzt noch diese interessante
Zahl so viele Erstklässler und
klässlerinnen gab es seit fast 20 Jahren
nicht mehr fast
831 000 sagt das Statistische Bundesamt
das waren rund 17 000 mehr als im
Vorjahr Gründe für den starken Anstieg
höhere Geburtenzahlen und die verstärkte
Zuwanderung vor allem aus der Ukraine
und irgendwann könnten aus erstglässlern
auch Unternehmer werden und von denen
wünscht sich das Wirtschaftsministerium
noch viel mehr und will mit der heute
beginnenden gründungswoche auch zeigen
wie das am besten gelingen könnte ein
Fokus liegt dabei auf Frauen die weniger
stark in der Gründerszene vertreten sind
aus Berlin Oman
leskowa nachhaltige Mode
selbsttherstellen dafür tauschten diese
beiden jungenfrauen ihre gut bezahlten
Jobs gegen die Selbstständigkeit ihr
Label ctopulli verwendet schonen
produzierte Stock Kinderpullover wachsen
über mehrere Größen mit fünf Angestellte
haben sie mittlerweile Umweltbelange
Ihnen besonders wichtig unsere größte
Motivation war auf jeden Fall die
Wirtschaft mitzugestalten und
unternehmerisch tätig zu sein ich bin
selber studierte Ökonomin und für mich
war es wichtig aufzuzeigen dass wir auch
andere Wege gehen können die vielleicht
morgen sogar normal sind aber irgendwer
muss sie ja gehen noch immer Gründen
weniger Frauen als Männer Unternehmen
während der Pandemie gab es kurzfristig
einen Anstieg im vergangenen Jahr aber
einen Rückgang aufs Ausgangsniveau dass
sich der positive Trend nicht verstätigt
führt der Verband Deutscher
Unternehmerinnen vor allem auf die
fehlende Vereinbarkeit von Beruf und
Familie zurück schwieriger sei auch das
Einwerben von Investitionen wenn sie um
sich um wagneskapital bewerben sitzen
sie oftmals rein männlichen
Gründungsteams gegenüber sie bekommen
auch andere Fragen gestellt sie müssen
viel öfter die Risiken aufzeichnen
zusätzlich gibt es Probleme die aktuell
Männer wie Frauen betreffen laut
Handelskammer ist das gründungs
Interesse insgesamt auf einem
historischen Tiefstand wir haben einfach
weniger Menschen in dem gründungsaffinen
Alter auf der anderen Seite ist das
wirtschaftliche Umfeld auch davon
geprägt dass wir nicht genau wissen das
ist im Unsicherheit in der Zukunft das
sieht man bei den Energiepreisen das
sieht man bei der Inflation die
Gründerinnen von oktopoli F ich das
nicht an sie sind überzeugte
Unternehmerinnen würden den Gang in die
Selbstständigkeit jederzeit
weiterempfehlen so jetzt weiter mit dem
Sport und du legst gleich mit Erfolgs V
Tennis los ja und durchaus einer kleinen
Überraschung denn Deutschlands Nummer 1
Alexander SEV hat sein Auftaktmatch bei
den ATP Finals in Turin gewonnen der
dreisatzerfolg gegen den wimmelten
Sieger Carlos alkaras aus Spanien Griet
allerdings fast in
Gefahr ein Sturz der böse Erinnerungen
wegt an zwer schwere Verletzung bei den
French Open 22 damals waren sämtliche
Bänder seines rechten Fußes gerissen
nach kurzem Schreckmoment aber scheint
festzustehen se linker Fuß nicht
umgeknickt offenbar nur gestaucht so
kann der zweimalige Gewinner dieses
saisonfinals der acht weltbesten Profis
sein frühes Break im dritten Satz ins
Ziel bringen auch Bruder mcha begeistert
Alexander zwerf gewinnt sein
auftagtmatch gegen den Weltranglisten
zweiten alkaras mit 6:7 6:3 und 6
Z4 ja und in der Fußball buundesliga
grüßt Bayer Leverkusen weiterhin von der
Tabellenspitze keine Niederlage ein
Unentschieden zehn Siege unter anderem
das 4:0 gestern gegen Union Berlin so
geht's entspannt in die
Länderspielpause Florian Wirz und
Jonathan t bringen aus ihrem Club
Selbstbewusstsein mit zum Treff der
Nationalelf in Frankfurt Leverkusen mit
Bundesliga Startrekord 31 von 33
möglichen Punkten Grimaldo bricht den
Bann beim 4:0 gegen Berlin gestern
kossonu und TA erhöhen nach eckbellen
das sieht alles schon ziemlich titelreif
aus von der Meisterschaft reden sie zwar
nicht aber ihr Optimismus wächst es gibt
ein Gefühl aber es gibt noch not
certainty was was wir den in mai
passieren keine Sicherheit also für das
Saisonende im Mai sicher aber ihr 4:0
Sieg nach dem Tor von non
Teller ja und doppeltes Glück und Gold
gestern bei der Trampolin WM in
Birmingham Großbritannien durch Fabian
Vogel und Ko laugstermann für Fabian
Vogel auf dem vorderen Trampolin war es
bereits der zweite WM-Titel während
synchronpartner ko laugtermann sein
finaldebü gab auch er überzeugte und
zeigte eine erfolgreiche Vorstellung
sagte aber er war vorher so unfassbar
aufgeregt komisch ganz komisch danke
schön Katja so es gibt Neuigkeiten von
der wohl berühmtesten Baustelle Europas
in Barcelona entsteht seit
121 Jahren die Sagrada Familia mit einem
abendlichen Festgottesdienst wurde jetzt
die Weihe von zwei weiteren nebentürmen
gefeiert gewidmet den Aposteln Matthäus
und Johannes noch unbeleuchtet die
Baustelle des Hauptturms in spätestens
10 Jahren soll Gaudi Sagrada Familia
dann endlich vollendet
sein ja fehlt noch das Wetter da warnt
der Deutsche Wetterdienst vor ergiebigem
Dauerregen und sturmböhen im Schwarzwald
und am Alpenrand mehr dazu gleich in den
Aussichten mit Katja
horneffer Journal gibt später um
21:45 Uhr mit Christian siers schönen
Dank fürs zuschauen schönen Abend und
bis
[Musik]
morgen guten Abend die neue Woche
startet mit Tiefs das Tief Jasper zieht
bis morgen Abend über Dänemark weiter
bis zur Ostsee und auch an den al
schüttet es ergiebig im Schwarzwald gab
es bis heute morgen innerhalb von 24
Stunden schon an die 60 Liter Regen pro
quadratmer und bis morgen Abend fallen
in Süddeutschland noch mal 30 bis 60 l
es wird also heute nach Dauerregen geben
in Süddeutschland und auch an den Küsten
regnet es kräftig dazu wird ein starker
ein stürmischer Wind aus
westsüdwestlichen Richtungen am ehsten
trocken bleibt es hier zwischen der
Lausitz und der Eifel die Temperaturen
sinken auf Werte von 13° am oberrein und
bis 5° an der Ostsee die
Höchsttemperaturen morgen liegen bei 9°
in den östlichen Mittelgebirgen und 14°
z.B im rheinminebiet und morgen übertag
regn es kräftig weiter im Süden und auch
in Norddeutschland bekommen Sie die
Sonne eher nicht zu Gesicht das sieht
Richtung Thüringen und Sachsen etwas
anders aus da bleibt's am ehsten trocken
da werden sie auch mal die Sonne sehen
am Mittwoch wird sich an diesem Wetter
noch wenig ändern am Donnerstag wird's
dann ruhiger und am Freitag kälter mit
nur noch 5 bis 10° guten Abend